okay here's a super easy question for
you why does zoro want to become the
strongest swordsman in the world as a
loyal one-piece fan this should be
pretty easy to answer for you right or
is it really see i recently asked myself
the very same thing and just like you
right now was shocked to find out that
we actually have no idea what zorro's
main motivation for his big dream
actually is
sanji wants to find the all blue because
he loves cooking robin wants to learn
about the true history because she wants
to honor the sacrifice of o'hara and
take down the world government chopper
wants to become a great doctor because
he wants to help even the sickest people
the only two people where neither you
nor me have any idea what their true
motivations really are are luffy and
yeah zorro the two most popular
characters of the entire series luffy
wants to become pirate king but oda
purposefully doesn't tell us his real
reason for it and zorro of course wants
to become the world's greatest swordsman
because
because why exactly i hope you agree
that it's probably not because he needs
to stroke his own ego really really hard
and while kawina was undoubtedly a big
catalyst for his growth he already
wanted to become the strongest even
before meeting her
[Music]
so what is it that drives zorro to put
his life on the line over and over again
for this big goal and i think you're in
luck because i think i managed to find
the key to fully unlocking zoro's
character by doing a complete socratic
deep dive into his character as deep as
no one has ever done before probably and
let me tell you in advance i think you
will be surprised by who zorro really is
and what he knew all along but be warned
this video will contain some monger
spoilers as well okay so i have to
shamelessly disclose here that zorro is
my favorite character and that the
original idea for this video was finding
out what made him so incredibly likable
and popular only by doing that research
did i accidentally stumble onto the
mystery behind his character so allow me
to guide you through my thought process
here if i held you at gunpoint to tell
me what makes zorro so likable you'd
probably say something like this hey you
me yeah you
why is zoro your favorite character were
you like some crazy sanji fan what did
you just call me i don't know
he's badass
and
swords something like that zorro is a
true badass no question about it but
there are clearly many other characters
that fit the stoic cool warrior trope
that are not as popular as xoro so i
figured there must be something more to
it something i can relate to that speaks
to me on a fundamental level however
instead of trying to analyze zorro i
decided to flip this on its head and
start with the audience myself
okay so one of my biggest insecurities
is that i personally sometimes feel
pretty lost in this vast and rapidly
changing modern world that we all live
in and so i asked myself what's the
deeper truth behind that well i guess
it's that i don't have a clear path in
life and the deeper truth behind that is
that i sometimes feel like i can't do
anything going deeper i guess that means
i sometimes don't have confidence in
myself meaning that i think i'm not
strong or capable enough to change and
influence things i want to change and
going one level deeper again the meaning
behind this is that i'm of no use to
anyone it means i don't deserve
attention and the truth behind that is
of course that i do want attention and
purpose now if you like zorro as well i
think you might be able to relate to
this breakdown i just did on myself
because as it turns out zorro is a
character that has a clear answer to
each and every one of these questions
even though he gets lost a lot
okay
he doesn't feel lost just the opposite
he has a very clear place in the world
fighting next to luffy he also has a
clear path he wants to become the
strongest swordsman no matter what and
because he has centered his entire
existence around this goal he is
actually strong strong enough to change
things that means zorro is confident in
his skills and in his ability to always
improve he knows he's strong and that he
can help others and so zorro is of use
to those he cares about as a result he
gets a lot of positive attention from
the people around him friends and foes
alike who all respect him for his path
and the biggest irony is zorro doesn't
even need this attention in the first
place he is okay being alone but even
more importantly he now has people
around him that genuinely care for him
marimo
so if you share my fundamental
insecurities zorro is like a cure for
that he's not relatable as much as he's
an inspiration and a role model for me
someone who fits the archetype of the
true hero an ideal person that is very
easy to look up to and be inspired by
especially for guys but for many girls
as well he's basically like a japanese
version of hercules the silent but
gentle warrior that follows the way of
the samurai to defend those who need him
and who never leaves this path even in
the face of death well except if it's a
literal path then you can be damn sure
that zorro will leave that faster than
you can say onigiri
[Music]
and what i realized in this moment is
that this is also the root cause for all
the conflict between people who like
sanji and people who like zorro now i
really love sanji and i love him because
he is so relatable he arguably is the
character with the most human and
emotional character development in all
of one piece sanji is all about growing
as a person and facing your own
insecurities
zorro on the other hand is not really
relatable but an ideal to strive towards
and while some people prefer to suffer
with sanji and emphasize with his
journey others prefer seeing an
idealized but admittedly unrealistic
version of what they would like to
become
and i mean that makes sense zaro's ark
so found the story has been very focused
on getting stronger physically otherwise
he has pretty much been the very
disciplined kind-hearted and loyal
person he is right now from the very
first chapter that we meet him now i do
think that oda has given him a little
bit of a personal arc as well where
being with luffy and the other straw
hats has made him ease up a bit more and
show more of his human side which is why
we all love the rare scenes where zoro
laughs or has a really human moment with
any of the other crew members
but overall he is already a close to
complete character the moment he joins
luffy and that brings me back to the
original question why does zorro want to
become the strongest swordsman now to be
fair i think it's absolutely plausible
that this is all oda ever wanted to do
with zorro have him be the perfect greek
god type of character that is easy to
look up to which many people me included
do already so you could definitely argue
that zorro doesn't need any deeper
motivation or a stronger theme than he
already has but the recent developments
in wano have been challenging that
perspective drastically for me and i
want to convince you that there is so
much more to nortonoa zoro than you
previously thought but first at break
real quick i want to talk about
skillshare the sponsor of today's video
thank you skillshare for sponsoring this
video skillshare is an online learning
community that offers thousands of
classes for all skill levels in tons of
creative and practical disciplines like
filmmaking cooking and art but it can
really be anything earlier this year i
learned how to do 10 finger typing yes i
know but better late than ever right or
you could for example also try a class
on animation i absolutely loved this
course by my fellow german colleagues
over at kurzgesagt on how they create
their wonderful animations the first
1000 of you foxes to click the link in
the description below will get a one
month free trial of skillshare premium
so you can start exploring your
creativity today now just like many of
the other straw hats zorro didn't join
luffy because he wanted to become a
pirate but because luffy offered them
the chance to reach their goal and why
does he have that goal well thinking
about that question made it painfully
clear to me that we actually don't know
zoro all that well when you really think
about it he doesn't talk much in general
and the moments where he shares
something about himself are very
very rare so i thought to myself let's
try the same deconstruction technique i
just used on myself but this time with
zorro
okay so we know for a fact that zorro
wants to become the strongest swordsman
so what is the deeper truth behind that
is it because he wants attention because
he needs someone to really stroke his
ego i think you know just as well as me
that this is not what zorro is all about
so there must be some other deeper
meaning behind all this when you really
break it down the idea behind the dream
is basically i want to be the strongest
full stop swordsmanship is simply the
way zoro grew up with given that he has
roots in wano which has now been pretty
much confirmed so swords are basically
just zorro's way of becoming strong just
as for luffy it's his devil fruit
[Music]
now being the strongest means that zoro
wants to be stronger than anyone else
and the deeper meaning behind that is
that he wants to be able to do what he
wants or needs to do there is something
he wants to change or defend or take
back that he only can do if he is
stronger than anyone else and so given
all the hints we've now gotten to zoro's
connection to wano and the shimotsuki
family i strongly believe that zorro's
real goal is and always has been to free
wano now i'm gonna give you a second to
process that and what better way to do
that and try out youtube's new crazy
feature where you can subscribe to my
channel by hitting the red button under
this video did that work now believe me
i totally understand that at first it
sounds really strange that zara wanted
to free wano all this time after all he
never mentioned it before but has he
ever mentioned anything about his
personal history or goals like
ever no i think that zorro just like
robin is a member of the straw hats that
knows much more about the world and what
is actually going on than they let on
think about it doesn't it make all the
sense in the world no matter if zoro was
born in wano or simply told of his home
after being born in the east blue he
grew up with the knowledge that orochi
and kaido were tyrannizing his country
shimotsuki uh
being related to the royal shimotsuki
family that ryuma was also part of makes
it very likely that he would have a very
deep emotional connection to the place
despite growing up in the east blue the
dojo where he met kawina is also heavily
connected to wano and seeing his
resemblance to the daimyo of ringo of
course they would want to keep him there
okay so you might still be skeptical
about this understandably but just for
the sake of argument let's just assume
for a second that this is actually true
and zoro wants to free wano despite
never having been there before so much
of the story suddenly makes sense of
course he'd want to become the strongest
swordsman if his goal was taking out
kaido and rochi zorro joins luffy in the
first place because he sees in him a
chance to get closer to wano and to his
goal throughout the story he is the most
serious about their journey and luffy
being a good captain because he has the
highest stakes in them actually making
it to the new world in wano knowing
right from the get-go what sort of
beasts they're going to be up against
seeing how far he is from mihawk at the
baratier i even made a whole video about
that show sorrow that he's not even
close to beating the man who might just
barely have a chance against kaido and
let me blow your mind about something
else the scene on thriller bark where
zaro sacrifices himself for luffy is one
of the most famous in the story
something i made a video about as well
now generally people tend to take
zorro's sacrifice here to mean that
luffy's dream is more important to him
than his own same as when he asks mihawk
to train him for luffy's sake throwing
away his honor
but when you look at it through the wano
lens zorro knows that luffy is the
person who will have the best chance at
taking on the likes of kaido and orochi
he is convinced that luffy is the one
who can actually free wano and change
the world and so it's not that he's
willing to give up his stream in
exchange for luffy's he inherits his
will to liberate wano to luffy to carry
it on for him similarly how does zorro
know that ryuma is from wano zaro is
clearly fully aware of what wano is like
all along
when they received the sos call from
punk hazard about a samurai zorro
immediately mentions it to brooke who is
the one who explains it to us but zorro
knows he clearly knows when they pick up
momo and kinemon on their way to
dressrosa and law explains the
flamingo's connection to kaido we see
nice we see the famous dots from zorro
and what i found really interesting is
that oda did not show us any of zoro's
reactions to all the one related reveals
on zou as well the only time we see his
face is when kinemon and momo reveal
that odin has been executed by kaido
literally everyone is shocked except
zorro he just looks more determined and
then of course we have zoro and wano
basically being a fish in the water
[Applause]
[Music]
all the moments with zorro fit really
nicely into the idea that this is the
place he wanted to come to all along but
i do want to pick out a few scenes in
particular for one we have the entire
plot line between him and hiyori seeing
arochi's execution of yasuye he goes for
orochi's head right away now if he had
grown up with the sole goal of killing
this man and then seeing his cruelty in
action for the very first time himself
of course he wouldn't be able to hold
back and go straight for his head now i
do agree that zaro also always wanted to
take down kaido but he has decided long
ago that he will leave kaido to luffy if
necessary just as it happened in the
manga orochi on the other hand i'm
convinced will fall to zorro's hands
this scene here with yori basically
confirms this and i'm pretty sure it's
zaro talking here all the way and i
think this would also fit really nicely
with the japanese legend of orochi who
was slain by the wind god susano by
getting the snake drunk on sake and then
killing it with the sword aminohabakiri
the sister sword of enma in one piece
zoro loving sake having been shown a
certain affinity to win style attacks
and a close relation to shinto buddhism
overall
[Music]
once again even after fighting kaido
himself zoro willingly is putting his
life on the line just to keep fighting
drinking the special medicine of the
minks as he says in this panel here all
that matters is being able to fight
right now he can't leave this one to
luffy alone it's what he has trained his
entire life for and he now has to do
everything he can possibly do to see
this battle through till the end when
kaido told the scabbards that wano will
never see a monster samurai like odin
again it only takes a couple of chapters
until zorro is called the mirrored image
of ryuma the most legendary samurai of
them all zorro says he will have all the
samurai of wano follow him in no time
and indeed he is a true king being able
to use congress hockey i'm convinced
that very soon we'll be getting a lot of
reveals surrounding zoro's origin and
based on what i just told you i'm pretty
sure that zorro knew way more about his
past and juano's past then oda
originally led us onto belief now if you
truly want to understand zaro's
character however you really have to
watch my analysis of him here next
thanks for watching